day had broken and the World As We Knew
It fell to pieces on every corner of the
globe devastating rays of sunshine have
liquefied most of the human race the
anomalous phenomenon known as scp-001
had made the most treasured source of
light and life in the Galaxy into the
harbinger of a planetary Apocalypse in
the streets of major cities which were
once so filled with culture and activity
melting Abominations slithered along the
sidewalks and pavement a cruel parody of
the crowds and traffic that existed in
the world before the drought ravaged
Wilderness teams with countless Globs of
mutant flesh that were once proud
members of the animal kingdom even the
plants have wilted into an inert State
overwhelmed by the sun's energy to the
point of being unable to photosynthesize
it there are no planes in the sky
anymore as no pilot falling on that day
could escape the view of daylight the
boundless ocean is adrift with boats and
cruise liners occupied by an aimless
crew of amalgamations which even the
initial survivors on the lower decks and
within the rooms have long since been
assimilated into in the early months of
scp-0011 day breaks the foundation had
been able to distribute rudimentary
information on how to Shield oneself
from the perversive Rays this included a
basic but comprehensive how-to guide on
building protective clothing that would
keep out all daylight unfortunately
there is only so much benefit these
Solutions can provide as it has become
too late to save the vast majority of
humanity from their terrible melting
fate there are sadly limits on what the
foundation's foresight and knowledge
could do to prevent a worst case
scenario and many containment sites were
lost within the first 24 hours alone
this means that the veil of normalcy
that the SCP Foundation had fought so
hard to preserve has effectively cease
to exist most if not all of the
accumulated research the containment
procedures for Dangerous anomalies and
the skilled Personnel who were Brave and
foolish to think they could keep the
world safe have met with terrible Fates
in this solar scarred Hells gay if there
was ever an era where the planet and the
universe were stable and under the
control of the foundation and the o5
council that time has passed this is not
their world anymore nor is it a world
that can be ruled by any people day has
broken and this is the world of monsters
today two of these monsters in
particular find themselves on a
collision course both were once
extremely dangerous cutter class scps
contained by the foundation but through
circumstance and Ingenuity both
anomalies had freed themselves and
adapted to the harsh new reality of the
outside world they were known as
scp-076-2 Abel and
scp-682 respectively able now known in
the Fireside stories of human survivors
as the black Warrior had given himself
an armored makeover by forging his many
weapons into a day-proof second skin
straight out of Dark Fantasy media this
new edgy gothic look came complete with
a massive sword that Abel could use to
cleave straight through any fleshy freak
Show he encountered in the Wasteland he
was a true living legend now a
mysterious hero a violent demon and a
force of nature all at once in the day
he stalked through the ruins of
civilization finding whatever passed for
worthy opponents and cutting them down
at night he would seek out those
depraved Souls who would Prey Upon their
fellow human and put them to the sword
these male factors had recently become
Abel's favorite Vermin to exterminate
since they always seemed so surprised to
be on the receiving end of an ambush
being a survivor in this hellish new
world was difficult enough without the
additional strain of plotting violence
so the ones who took advantage of the
absence of laws and did so were either
exceedingly clever or simply driven out
of their wits by the desire to inflict
harm it was through several experiences
stomping out the lingering scum of the
earth that Abel discovered an unfamiliar
sense of Honor within himself it wasn't
that he grew accustomed to protecting
frail humans from Monsters but rather
the simple fact that a good fight
required two mutually adversarial
parties Bandits and serial killers could
routinely be counted on to have
delusions of grandeur accompanied by ill
intentions while their hapless victims
could not in his own Twisted way Abel
had accepted that showing Mercy to
cowards and weaklings suited his ends
after all if there were no more
Innocents Left Alive there would also be
no more reprobates to Menace them his
Quarry needed something to bait them
into emerging from the Shadows after all
despite having made the most of slim
picking there was a deep-seated part of
Abel that longed for a real challenge
the black Warrior wished to face a real
monster like himself again not the petty
brutes and former human sludge he'd been
using as substitutes 682 would be an
ideal opponent but he hadn't seen the
reptile since he was back in containment
the two had been made to fight each
other the day before all of this began
and when during the continued breach
that later ensued 682 had a makeover of
its own the highly morphic lizard had
tunneled its way out of sight 19 by
evolving barge scooping claws suited for
subterranean travel being surprisingly
intelligent for its animalistic shape
682 had managed to torture the details
of the scp-001 scenario out of an
unlucky researcher while Abel had found
a way to remain active during both day
and night
scp-682 had become a bit more selective
in its schedule this was possibly
because the creature had adapted an
internal clock by absorbing the
previously mentioned researchers
wristwatch while the sun was visible in
the sky 682 would remain dormant
underground there it could bask in the
Symphony of suffering from all the
surface dwelling living things it could
perceive with its enhanced hearing it
would lie and wait for hours
anticipating the darkness of Nightfall
once the sun had set
scp-682 would emerge and devour both
human and Abomination alike as a being
that harbored pure hatred for all things
that lived the reptile had far less
Discerning criteria for acceptable
targets than able it Unleashed its wrath
on anything that so much has gotten its
way during the nightly Feeding Frenzy
another way that 682 differed from Abel
in its post-apocalyptic way of life was
that it hadn't been given any evocative
nickname or title the reason why was
surprisingly simple 682 hadn't made its
existence known because any survivors
that encountered it never lived to tell
the tale
it was a surprise to both of them when
late one night a twist of fate brought
the monsters back together
scp-682 had just resurfaced near a small
encampment of survivors and was
approaching with the attention to
Massacre the panicking humans as the
hateful reptile Drew closer it noticed a
dark figure lurking at the other side of
the campfire it was roughly the size of
an average humanoid but instead of
running and screaming the figure stood
firm with an enormous sword in one hand
one of the fleeing humans cried out it's
the black War career we're saved this
amuse 682 and its sported a sadistic
grin as it ran toward the Survivor and
pounced while the lizard had wanted to
demonstrate how flimsy the human sense
of Salvation really was the opposite
took place the so-called black Warrior
had intercepted its jaws and was
blocking 682 with only his sword and all
the Superhuman strength he could put
behind it go now little ant the black
Warrior said following Abel's command
the human fled looking back over its
shoulder only once to gaze at the black
warrior in silent awe with that
straggler gone the two monsters were now
completely alone in the camp both
illuminated by the orange glow of
firelight they separated and began to
Circle each other memories of their old
rivalry began flooding back as both of
the now liberated Qatar classes
confirmed the identity of the other
scp-682 began to laugh as it recognized
The Stance of the ancient warrior that
had been such a Thor born in its side
back in containment isn't this Priceless
the proud and merciless able has become
a defender of those disgusting humans
scp-682 said wearing that horrible smile
once again I am not fighting for them
the black Warrior answered he lunged
forward striking a hard blow against
682's carapace the edsword bounced
upward in Recoil but not without
inflicting a deep wound that 682's
regeneration began to work overtime to
repair the reptile swiped at Abel with
its scoop claws then made further use of
them by burrowing into the ground below
Abel knew better than to follow the
creature underground and he was almost
sure that his scaly Nemesis hadn't yet
retreated he held his ground and waited
stealing himself for the moment the
creature revealed itself once more as
expected the attack came from directly
below
scp-682 breached the surface and snapped
its jaws around one of Abel's armored
legs trusting his instincts the black
Warrior struck back in the same moment
his sword stabbed into the reptile's
jaws and with a bit of strength he
leveraged his own leg free the armor was
dented but fortunately there was no
apparent holes left by 682's fangs able
had become accustomed to diligently
maintaining the condition of his armor
as even the smallest crack could in the
daylight hours cause him to lose his
solid form forever he'd made sure to do
a more thorough investigation later
after the lizard had been put in its
place the black Warrior fought
defensively minimizing the damage to his
armor while timing his strikes to keep
682 from overwhelming him with sheer
offense he could certainly go all out if
he chose to but that same part of him
that wanted a challenge was willing to
prolong the conflict especially if he
could save himself the trouble of
repairs later
scp-682 on the other hand didn't much
care for being taken lightly and was
astute enough to notice when his foe
wasn't as aggressive as usual it had
been over a year since the monsters had
fought but this time there would be no
Foundation Personnel to end the fight
prematurely 682 decided it was time to
give the armored Edge Lord an onslaught
that he couldn't ignore it began to
rotate its tunneling claws like a pair
of pneumatic excavators and instantly
showered the black warrior with dirt and
debris as it burrowed back into the
Earth Abel could deflect the Rocks
easily enough but the temporary
distraction gave 682 time to dig a large
enough Cavern beneath Abel's feet that
the ground instantly collapsed beneath
his armored bulk Abel slid into the
growing pit and straight towards the
twin grinding claws of 682 he tried to
use his sword in the ground to slow his
descent but the Earth had been so
thoroughly tenderized by his opponent
that all he accomplished was hastening
it just like an ant lion larva
scp-682 had created a Death Pit of
detrus that was pulling Abel towards the
center of its trap as if making a
Whirlpool on land wasn't crazy enough
for 682 the reptile grew itself an array
of impaling horns across the front of
its face and snout though can
constructed of Flesh and Bone they had
the appearance of serrated blades and
possessed a sharpness and durability
capable of penetrating through Abel's
fancy new suit of armor but the black
Warrior wasn't going to be defeated so
easily especially not after all the work
he had put in during his latest life to
forge these armaments while clutching
his giant blade in one hand he conjured
a new weapon from the Shadows a harpoon
with a strong chain that appeared
already wrapped tightly around his black
gauntlet Abel hurled the Harpoon behind
him with as much strength as he could
manage in his nearly prone state and as
he hoped its tip embedded itself in the
more stable ground past the edge of the
Death Pit with the spear firmly secured
at the other end the chain went taut and
Abel was able to stop himself just short
of falling on
scp-682's facial spikes with a
tremendous one-handed swing that would
be impossible for a mortal man Abel cut
through the middle of the lizard's
organic bayonets rendering them
practically useless his metal boots dug
into the slit and with all his strength
he wrenched himself backwards towards
the top of the pit tearing the Harpoon
free in the process with acute Precision
he used the chain to direct the tip of
the Harpoon between the fractured bone
blades and into 682's skull the creature
bellowed from the sudden pain and began
to dig downward again but by this time
Abel was on stable Earth again and was
pulling with all his strength on the
other side of the chain
scp-682 burrowed as furiously as it
could but the Harpoon embedded in its
head was throwing off its equilibrium
Abel planted his feet and kept pulling
summoning more weapons around his feet
and legs to keep them from moving an
inch back toward the pit it was a
Titan's tug of war and whoever gave in
would surely be at the mercy of the
other neither monster wavered and the
thing that broke Under The Strain was
the chain itself 682 tunnel the way
Harpoon still scratching its brain and
did not surface again that night while
the black Warrior staggered as he
retrieved his now broken length of chain
Abel waited for his hated foe to
resurface but the creature had
apparently decided it was no longer
interested in a fight and it was just as
well because in the East the sun was
Rising again the black Warrior moved
inside one of the tents that the
survivors had left behind and prepared
for a full examination of his armor
while it didn't last and no SCP save for
scp-001 could claim victory here Abel
was grateful to know there were still
proper adversaries to fight after the
end want to own an SCP of your own go to
scpswag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise now go check out could
scp-076 able survive scp-001 when day
breaks and scp-001 when daybreaks
scp-682 to see how it all started